Ben is with us in Chicago hi Ben welcome
to the Dave Ramsey show thank you for
having me
sure how can I help so I'm a 20 year old
21 year old third year student at
Community College I went to Community
College to save some money so I wouldn't
go into debt right now I'm looting rent
free at home I don't have any expenses
maybe pay a couple times for gas and
groceries I do have one credit card but
there's no debt on that I pay it off
immediately and I'm looking to transfer
to a four-year when I can and I was just
curious what I can do in preparation for
this big move okay
very cool are you gonna stay at home all
you're gonna do in the four year that is
undecided yet I have about forty to
fifty thousand saved up for college
right now Wow my parents and family were
very smart and they saved up so I mean
pretty good standing there you only need
two years to finish if all this trans
community stuff transfers right yeah I
saw many some of the college then
looking at would like 80 credit hours
which would be about two to two and a
half years so it would be just around
there but if I wanted to go somewhere
more expensive and I was looking at
flight school at one point that would be
an extra you know sixty thousand dollars
mm-hmm okay well I don't mind what you
do as long as you have the money so you
know whatever the goal is let's start
figuring out the parallel income stream
that's going to hit the goal for you
so first goal is finish your degree at
the four-year institution and you should
be able to do that for 40 grand easy
all right yeah yeah and I have
investigated the cost of college and
yeah so around me the only thing that's
the problem right now is that I'm going
to be a transfer and the transfer
scholarships are a little bit less than
you know if you just happen straight
into college from high school right so a
lot of colleges then looking at would be
around 20 a year so I mean it'd be right
around that $40,000 but if I wanted to
do something a little more expensive I
was just curious you know what I would
be able to do to kind of prepare myself
for that scholarships and jobs okay that
would be it I mean you got the money so
you know so what you need to do is very
clearly define what your next step is
and exactly what it's going to cost and
what the cost what the schedule of the
money needs are okay
so let's pretend that you were going to
do something I'm not sure you need to
but let's pretend as an example that you
said okay to finish up my degree at the
school I want to go to is going to be
sixty thousand we have forty thousand
that means I'm ten thousand a year short
or I'm ten thousand dollars in the last
year short one of the two right yeah I'm
twenty short if I need sixty and I got
forty and you actually go talk to the
school you actually get their tuition
you lay out exactly what your budgets
going to be you have a game plan well
then you got to go about finding that
twenty thousand bucks in scholarships
and or jobs between now and the time
that you have to write that check now if
you've got two years to come up with 20
grand it's ten thousand dollars a year
it's eight hundred bucks a month that's
two nights a week delivering pizza yeah
okay and so you can be done I mean
there's a way to get at this but you
just got to figure out you know what
exactly is your goal and one of the
things we ask ourselves around here in
business and we do it in personal
development as well is once you set your
goal you clearly define it it's clearly
measurable it has a time frame on it so
the math plays out right in front of you
and you say okay everything I need is
$38,000 I got 40 so that gives me to to
move towards flight school so I can move
on to the next goal or you say I'm going
so I'm gonna need 60 I got 40 so I got
to find 20 on XYZ schedule then you
start at that's your desired for you
sure as we call it and then you start
asking yourself okay what has to be true
that's not true now well I gotta find 20
grand right by this date and how am I
gonna find 20 grand I'm gonna work doing
X Y or Z and I'm gonna go get a B and C
scholarships and I'm gonna put those two
things together and they're gonna equal
more than 20 grand if I want to go to
flight school and I'm you I'm doing this
on the cheap I'm going to the cheapest
place to finish undergrad I can and have
as much of that 40 left over and then I
got a head start on flight school rather
than going I want to go to this other
place it costs more than I've got and
then you got a you know you're gonna
you're coming out dead broke and no
money for your flight school so you do
whatever you want to do but that's how
goal-setting works is you set the thing
out real clearly you cannot wander into
this blindly and just pray that money
drops from heaven it's not going to when
you do that that's called student loans
and then 30-year old you is pissed off
at the 20 year old you for doing the
stupid stuff and so don't do that have a
plan lay it out in detail really really
good question